bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vigenti oggi siamo su siri
è di cosa l'importante è che tu sei
felice
sono felice e primi tre ragazzi malati
che sto in tantissimi di far sarò da
quando ho fatto video quello su dungeon
hunters quindi facciamo sto benedetto
video consigli è una roba non ho mai
parlato con un robot
proprio come se fosse mia sorella è vero
che se mia sorella zia purtroppo non so
cosa rispose perché è sempre difficile
per la gente ammettere di essere un mio
parente perché c'è basta vedermi con che
ragazzi a parte tutto vediamo se riesco
a trovare allora mi ha sbagliato non ho
sbagliato sbagliato sbagliato ecco cosa
ho trovato cercando allora suo interno
non dice chiara allora suite per
facilitare la cosa ragazzi ho scritto su
facebook
fatemi delle domande da fare a siri così
che tutti voi possiate chiederle
qualcosa vediamo che cosa avete scritto
porca vacca sta cadendo microfono ma
prima si fa mi un panino con la nutella
subito va bene
siri farmi un panino con la nutella
subito non mi è permesso di avvicinarmi
ai fornelli
se sei donna quindi band in cucina
subito non lasciare che la mia voce king
anni non ho un fesso non hai un sesso
cosa vuol dire senti zia che conosco un
metodo infallibile per sapere che sesso
6 guardati nei pantaloni e dimmi che
cosa vedi te vedi e perché va beh se non
vedi e perché ok
ecco cosa anche l'autostop no no no no
mio dio one direction cosa centrale one
direction se non puoi avvicinarti i
fornelli che mansioni fi
se il sapore buono a te fa male però
questo è vero cazzo qualsiasi cosa di
buono fa male anche le crepes alla
nutella fanno male
[Musica]
ave ragazzi passiamo alla prossima
ciao sinché casata di hogwarts sei stata
smistata va beh ciao si ascolta mai che
casata di hogwarts sei stata smistata
vediamo cosa eccesso twitter su twitter
una serie di tweet ma che cazzo me ne
frega dei grifondoro serpeverde domanda
più diretta
se i griffin griffin d'oro no a norcia
scherzando scherzando peters scherzando
tranquillo no ma griffin un'altra dei
grifondoro serpeverde se insisti alla
reiss france dove sapone anno le feci
dell'armadillo ma che domande mi partner
emanuela ci scrive digli che la ami e
poi la prendi per il culo va bene sì io
ti devo dai fammi finire [ __ ] siri io
ti devo confessare una cosa io ti amo ma
se mi conosce bene ma come guardie
cinque minuti per un ragazzo soltanti
harry che cosa pretende questa che
possiamo una vita insieme a batteria è
però io ti amo e che devo farci tu mi
ami scusa fa finta di non aver sentito
sto scherzando ti stavo prendendo per il
culo che linguaggio ma se tv parma che
voi racconta una barzelletta siri almeno
almeno capiresti le barzellette nella
mia lingua in ogni caso non sono molto
divertenti
perché scusami che lingua parli fammi
capire tanto conto che agisce una lingua
che si chiama o tutto ok cerchiamo lassù
traduttore perché si trova ai serie t
andremo un po di schweppes sono io e te
ho già tutto quello che mi sei no però
la chance con me non ce l'hai ancora e
credimi che non sarà lascerebbe scappare
nessuno quindi niente chef zia non so
bene cosa no niente sesso niente chef si
però le devi uscire perché sono le c che
cazzo stiamo affatto
faccio finta di non aver cioè fai finta
di aver sentito senti ma stasera che fai
sto rispondendo alle tantissime
richieste che mi arrivano non c'è
bisogno che ti dica che non ha solo
quelle che arrivano dal pianeta terra
sì sì mi scusi reca io non volevo
recarle disturbo mi perdoni sua
gran magnificenza mi dispiace e mi
dispiace mi dispiace a me mi dispiace se
bello siri facciamo l'amore con il
sapore non è neanche una domanda proprio
dobbiamo avere accettato grazie zia che
dici cercare su internet ma ascolta zia
se io dicessi ricercare un video di fa
vj fa vj tutto attaccato per l'amor di
dio t'ammazzo cosa risponderesti mi
dispiace no no e no dai non scrivere
farisei con la j staccata è come
scrivere chiara chiaro a cola a staccata
che cazzo mib rappresenta madonna di non
avessi scrivere far jj con la jay
staccato come si vecchia araki vecchia
racchia arc la star non faccio finta è
brava non aver sentito la senti mi
stanno dicendo che mi tradisci con
cleverbot è vero se i tuoi portare i
pantaloni t adesso abbiamo capito bene
in mezzo alle gambe che cleverbot
scritto bimbominkia e geniale con
creazioni sto facendo questo video serio
e sto facendo questo video mentre ho la
febbre e anche alta purtroppo però lo
faccio perché sono rimanete senza video
poi i cristiani quindi è
chiediamo a siri cosa possiamo fare per
la febbre syria e qualche rimedio per la
febbre
mi dispiace grazie bravissima vita
meglio di un medico sono i tuoi genitori
ma questa qua non c'ha manco lui il cane
che cazzo
siri chi sono i tuoi genitori la mia
camilli e sei tu fila in cucina
immediatamente prepararmi un cazzo di
panino ti sculazzo manco fosse l'ultima
cosa che faccio ma e le impostazioni di
localizzazione scorri fino a siri
dettature consenti l'accesso alla
posizione è la cosa più dolce che mi
abbia mai detto in tutta la sua vita
ragazzi blindi con la supercazzola con
scappellamento a sinistra certo allora
siri e blindi con la supercazzola con
scappellamento a sinistra è intanto
trini la confraternita pulitina mi ha
appena contro super cazzolato come
minchia fa sapere ma se le civette
facevano l'amore con la figlia del
dottore ma la figlia del dottore proprio
tocco la perché mi fate scaduto non
credo di meritare questo trattamento
perché se la figlia di un dottore cerca
immagini su fa vj su internet
ecco delle immagini di fatti non lo
trovate su internet fa vj grazie cos'è
questa cross ma ieri e metteste fatti la
verità che vorresti il mio numero di
telefono dopo aver visto quanto sono
sexy 6 attraente per me essere
[Musica]
ok la smettiamo sia i ragazzi grazie
anche anche tu sei molto bella e non
sono neanche ubriaco sto dicendo perché
si può più bella caso se tutti sono in
pieno quello che sta ore di james una
nuova mascotte ami yogo non capisco
perchè parli sempre di nuvole che
minchia 6 goku voglio chiedere
seriamente
errare humanum est perseverare autem
diabolicum
ma a questo punto la tenebra affanculo e
chi s'è visto s'è visto
parla la tipa questo perché prima nov
affanculo enea che cosa centra enea
povero cristiano via scusa enea se stai
guardando questo video non ti ho mandato
a [ __ ]
lei ha capito male capisce una minchia
ne hai mai fumato cocaina guardando
anatre fare la pipì i ragazzi ma vi
drogate a farsi domande ma lo sai che mi
hanno regalato un coso di sasha grey
nell'ultimo vlog è stato veramente
brutto zia non ho trovato nulla su sasha
gray su internet
ce n'è di roba grading siri
teletrasporta mi togli la cintura le
scarpe ma già altri svuota le tasche
subito se non c'ho la cintura non c'ho
le scarpe la giacca annuncerò cio pura
febbre svuota le tasche ma lavava un
culo vai vai vai sono pronto c'è un
timer oppure intenzione di fare in
fretta
ok ecco l'italia ecco il termine che ha
prima che ci arriva finito il via faccio
più andare a piedi zia quanti abitanti a
fa vj ok
ecco cosa ho trovato su internet su
quanti abitanti e fa dj favo favo favo
fa lo costituisce fondalmentalmente
inventati da jay me e vedi che c'è
sempre la j staccata minka anche lì
perché scrivono tutti i favi geico sta
minkia dj staccata spiegano ti prego se
mi dà una risposta interessata ma lo
sapevo anch'io con ragazzi spero che
video vi sia piaciuto che un crollo mi
episodio con siri perché non manco
saputo dare i consigli sulla febbre come
una neuro fai schifo
la minchia però che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi io concludo che episodio se
avete delle domande da fare a sirio
magari gliele pongo nel senso che gliele
faccio nonché col pongo nel prossimo
video consigli che ci rivedremo vero
ziativa se ci rivediamo
che si accontenta gode dipende è troppo
piccolo questo buco non godiamo una
mazza se video è piaciuto così tanto
meno mi piace anche a pagina di facebook
come noi video tratta una descrizione se
avessi discrete received a orgosolo vito
siri merda farò finta di non aver
sentito